foreign
we used to have exam boards when I was
in the psychology department and there
was one year where a student gave an
excuse for a low Mark that their
grandparents had died and the external
examiner who was a psychologist said
grandparent I'm not sure that's
traumatic if it had been the parent yes
now this is the problem that we have
that we're using a category and telling
people when and when they're not allowed
to talk about trauma where I my argument
is that we need to take seriously how
people are using trauma it may be in the
course of describing what they
experience that they think yeah okay
maybe it wasn't so traumatic but I think
we had to give people the space to talk
about it and think about it for
themselves rather than a psychiatrist or
a psychologist telling them what they
should or shouldn't and I do and I
definitely I'm sympathetic I don't want
to draw boundaries and say this is
traumatic and this isn't I definitely am
sympathetic to your um people should be
able to narrate their own trauma and
recognize their own trauma and
definitely sympathetic to that
perspective and actually I do buy that I
still worry that if people left to their
own devices are able to use that term
and use that framing for something which
um
then means they're not able to exercise
emotional resilience I mean other types
of coping mechanisms which are actually
dampened down because of their framing
it as traumatic That's My worry is that
um that we're seeing a reduction in
resilience of of young people and I see
this in my students crikey I'm so
worried about them the levels of anxiety
depression they feel very traumatized by
things and I don't want to tell them
it's not trauma but I'm seeing them
they're not making friends they're
staying inside like they're I'm worried
about their emotional landscape and I'm
worried that they're labeling is
actually impeding their capacity to
build resilience and that's the point
I'm trying to make rather than Force
things into categories
foreign
do you think you can spot resilience on
a brain scan you are can you spot
resilience on a brain oh well I love
this question analysis
bring it back to the brain so yeah
so we can definitely see trauma in the
brain you know this is why this is what
I started with this is the brain scan
it's coming so yeah so when I would scan
people with um who had suffered traumas
like and then you would see an area
called the amygdala it was hyperactive
and that's an area that's involves yes
fear but General salience it's part of
the limbit network you would see hyper
um or altered activation of the uh
hippocampus which is an area involved in
memory you'd see loads and loads of
loads of activation in the insular my
favorite brain region which is involved
in the sensing of bodily physiology so
the racing heart the autonomic responses
that you see with trauma and you see a
reduction or altered activity in the
vmpfc the ventral medial prefrontal
cortex which is an area involved in
regulation and and this is what you
classically see in people that have had
a trauma
um episode and they're finding it hard
to regulate their emotional reactions to
it and so conversely resilience we'll be
seeing
um a greater engagement of controlled
areas in the brain which are able to
dampen down and inhibit this emotional
reaction so prefrontal cortex and
actually you can see that the white
matter tract between the vmpfc and the
amygdala the Integrity of that tract
predicts the degree to which you have
anxiety symptoms the idea being that if
that tract is is better you are more
resilient and you're more able to
regulate these things and yeah I can't
even remember
my original question was you know can
you define resilience
for a glossary of terms for this
but yes sir titles
and resilience is very much linked to
the activation of these prefrontal areas
which is involved in control control of
emotion and Regulation and I worry that
if people are spending too much time
talking about their trauma and exploring
the emotions attached to it I'm worried
they're not engaging enough this
circuitry or they're loading too much on
this emotional reaction and they're not
able to build up the resilience in the
same way words can frame the emotional
reactions in the brain so can any of the
three of you invisible way in which
these remarkable discoveries can change
or do something about this to use your
word the dangerous seepage of troll of
seepage of History you know can we use
these scientific insights to actually
Reach Out And Touch the psychologic
insights about to meet somewhere
clinically useful to change the way we
go forwards
I think we have to take this point that
you raised about the uh The Power of
Words very very seriously and we need to
think about the ways in which our brain
is an incredibly plastic organ that the
brain chemistry and the Brain structure
changes according to what's happened to
us it's not simply that the brain is
ticking away and then doing things and
then we behave in certain kinds of ways
it's as much the other way around as
well and I think we need to
conceptualize these scans that you use
as the basis of your research not only
in terms of what has happened before
events but also to conceptualize how
people's experience then has an effect
on their brain structure which then
shows up in the scans that's my first
caution my first worry uh that it's a
more complicated relationship between
the two than a simple causal effect a
biological effect working its way out
into practice practice my other worry is
that these scans require require a great
deal of interpretation and that's what
you're skilled in you're skilled in
reading these scans and reading scans
that have already been interpreted in
the process of injecting the chemicals
and working out what bits light up where
okay if you put there was a lovely
experiment a few years ago where a group
of neuroscientists brought a frozen
North Atlantic salmon in the fmri and
they were able to show that the Frozen
North Atlantic salmon in the scanner
engaged with the tasks
is that there's a degree there's a big
degree of uncertainty which is we fill
in the gaps in our interpretation and we
need to be careful about where those
interpretations come from so so although
I agree with you that you made some
valid points there's definitely a
difference in the brain for people who
have had some of these very traumatic
events versus those who have not
um had the sort of medically
um classified traumatic events so that
is definitely true and not up for
interpretation but I want to come to a
different point I want to come to the
point of behavioral activation and my
understanding of it it's about
um treatments for depression
um uh and and pain and other things by
making the outside world more engaging
so it's taking a focus away from self
and onto the world
and these things are shown to have a
positive effect and I take from this and
our brains oscillate between internal
processing and external processing and
this comes back to yeah your sentence
about you know self-reflection that if
we spend too much time focusing on
self-analyzing self analyzing trauma
then we're activating these circuits
which are very much implicated in
depression and anxiety and it becomes
reinforcing and one way you can help
people is get them out to themselves
focus on the world focus on helping
someone focus on you know an interesting
lecture focus on something else and
they'll start that they can start to
feel better again and it's a they can I
had the webcam I had the word can but I
wanted to know did the salmon feel
better
I'm worried about the sun yeah let's
haven't got caught
what happens on salmon
and it was a problem because the salmon
was dead
then it was but it's a long it's a long
story and uh
yeah but no it's very different for what
I do
I do I don't do fish
and you're watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV